[Music]
welcome back to the fine
the show where I give my audience the
wonderful opportunity of giving me free
content you are welcome that's right
clap it up everybody boy oh boy did we
get some great memes from last week's
did you submit your meme don't worry
I'll wait in the meantime have I told
you about this chair this chair it's
only 319 a it's got the head support the
lumbar support you can't see it's real
sturdy if you're really fat
[Music]
you will still be able to sit on it if
we sell a hundred more of these meme
review no no no this isn't the why get
it right you dummy in treasonous already
crows
the next episode my best friend goes
well that would be actually true if
you'd answer my calls Jack I called you
late at night tell you my feelings and
all I hear is awkward sighing and
moaning what happened
I've seen this bleeding meme about five
thousand times why do people upload this
the Logan Paul meme is dead stop it
fixing someone else's post Jesus Christ
man what even is this means are so weird
these days man I don't even how deep can
you go hey that's pretty deep
meme that's a pretty cool artwork I
actually really like that one thank you
very much warm a cup of battery acid the
most reliable news source Wall Street
Journal or Punic death trap does he bite
no but he can hurt you in other ways God
got him good thank you
why don't they make a bulletproof vest
out of diamond I've seen this one if
it's the hardest metal because it's too
heavy one gram of diamonds weight
something like 15 grams one gram weight
something like 15 grams I mean it's true
diamond is heavier so it waves more
think about how heavy that suit must be
where's jumpscares of all time we got it
slender man finance and Freddie's did
that actually scare you Wow what a bunch
of crybabies oh he got out of the closet
that scared me
bunch of homophobes that's what you are
a man can't leave the closet you don't
get scared
disgusting I thought we were better than
that on this channel I thought we
weren't progressive high five watch and
learn Logan Paul there were so few dead
people in Japan it was really not that
hard I don't understand kind of
disappointed wait
don't jump PD is back that's right he is
back hey hooray and I won't blog it
either no I won't [ __ ] connect the
classics can
okay man you guys gotta freshen up on
your Mema pedia guys okay alright okay
you're you're a couple you're a bit late
the best memes I just wasted goddamnit
hiding from a serial killer oh my god
I'm gonna die if he finds me killer good
guy PewDiePie went to Japan didn't film
a dead but that's right
this is a fake article why do I not get
the credit I deserve nice guy beauty but
no one talks about him chemistry can be
fun in Sweden what are you burning what
is this this better not be an okay sign
I swear to God Wow how about god dammit
I am so shocked wow you really got me
maybe burn the flame a little slower
next time alright what is this 188 no no
180 excuse me get first of all worse
that's wasting Italian leather huh what
is the lumbar support what are you gonna
care about your bank now you can't put a
price on your back what else can you do
hey what about this yeah I don't think
so miss maybe that gay [ __ ] bit connect
broke ohms that's right that's where
your money's gonna be a oh thank you
poor sleepy rest is so your mom gay no
you ha got you that's good I'm not okay
with art theft I'm very strongly against
it haha
memes are not art get your head out of
your ass boy
plus you steal the memes - I know I know
you do I forgot to pick up some milk FBI
agent look outside so cute he protect he
marry but most importantly he bring the
dairy son dad why is my sister named
unicorn dad your your mom wanted to name
her after something that never existed
son makes sense thanks dad dad no
problem video of pide pide dying okay if
you're new on the channel you might not
understand this joke it's basically
based on real-life facts that I have
never died in a video game cuz I'm an
I'm a pearl player I've actually never
made any mistake in my entire life I've
never made any form of wrong judgment
moves or everything just comes natural
to me it's easy if I see a dead body in
the wood site I think to myself you know
what I might just do a selfie and that
will be it but anything more will just
be distasteful so I move on and I don't
end up in any badge debacles
and when I get really mad in pub G at
the bridge I think to myself hey don't
let your your deeper darkest sorry I
worked forever to make this for parents
it's absolutely horrendous I'm sorry
what is that a poop underneath my nose
there's my notice that big just kidding
I love the style it looks really cool
Edgar looks like he enjoys us too right
dead girl you love it he says yes so sad
pukes how long is this video
Brad 9 appearance oh my god you're so
mean I have no memes to review Fitz
commits suicide
Brad misses spits grape bread seconds
past 10 minutes even like if you cried
leave a like right now if you cried I
know you cry or at least press F up
though it appears there's a one our love
why since he has so much new stuff
oh please okay I can barely get to ten
minutes what do you think the ten
minutes in video is ten minutes long
because I'm too lazy because I don't
want to put more effort than what is
required no no not at all it's because
there's not enough content one hour
gotta hear oh my god
now that's attractive Burger King for it
loud ice it's not funny don't make fun
of his voice he's got the autism brother
King footlights don't make fun of his
voice please
Burger King suck Gladys momma can [ __ ]
I'm scared it's supposed to be scary
well what the hell is this name review
all the memes and their ratings all
that's awesome
I need to do like a website or some
something like that where you guys can
vote as well los got a 10 I didn't
remember that but miss me
oh that's awesome
thank you for putting that together
that's great we are entering the main
page of memes this is where the spice of
this sambhoga is laying that was amazing
well done Nick gbus thought you were
gonna trick me to say something there I
love seeing people smile at their phones
in public had they received happy news
is it a text from a loved one perhaps
what could be instilling such joy in
that moment baby by that return that's
right
come here let me wipe your tears away
sorry let me wait let me wipe them away
there you go
that's right don't cry don't cry
you see if earth isn't flat
why can't pay the price chair do this
but not dead
[Music]
cuz that would be gay upload if you want
Brad to make a video compilation of
pewds awkwardly trying to jump awkwardly
trying to get in the closet and then
jump it no no Brad you Brad
can we censor them please that's
disgusting
so looking at the meme I was looking at
it this drawing has taken 39 hours I
hope you like it
but it's okay oh because this drawing is
taking 38 hours I hope you like it
whoa that's amazing I think I do prefer
this one just a hint bit but man this is
this is incredible thank you very much
art I see monkeys I'm honored seriously
the guys are so talented in anything
besides memes of course Petey pie please
meme hunter like aww there's three
layers of PewDiePie in this video now
the next horror game that's gonna go
viral today we are making meat bars
today we're making sweet sweet so good I
don't mean this to be offensive but my
theater should know how to cook Swedish
meatballs okay moving on this is all
whoa damn that's so cool
that's sick sleepy sadly this is one of
my favorites ever that's so cool I wish
my setup was that purple that looks so
sick anxiety what if something to goes
around depression what's the point
Felix cage Elbert please buy my place by
this chair we need to sell a hundred
more come on everybody
hundred more everybody come up fight the
chair I'm tired of plugging it do you
care about your
[Music]
that was awful he started to it turn
into a high-five and it just fell apart
it was I never want to do that again I
never want to do that again I never want
to do that again I never want to do that
again well we never did that again so
that's why he professed yes guys this
was this week's episode of the why it's
good to be back I thank you make sure to
post your memes into the Y and become
immortalized by posting by becoming into
a PewDiePie video the highest honor in
the whole world make sure to leave a
like
and by the chair
[Music]